c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 est la
une ce soir macky sall qui plaide pour
l'octroi d'un siège à l'union africaine
au sein du g20 le président du sénégal
et président en exercice de l'ua a pris
la parole ce mardi devant l'assemblée
générale des nations unies qui l'a
également appelé à donner plus de voix
au continent au sein du coup ce conseil
de sécurité de l'onu
l'inquiétude en ouganda les autorités
sanitaires et l'om s ont annoncé avoir
détecté une flambée du virus ebola dans
le pays un premier mort a été enregistré
une épidémie trois ans après le dernier
décès causés par cette maladie mortelle
la crise agricole qui plane sur la
guinée le pays très dépendant des
engrais en provenance de la russie a du
mal à s'en procurer la pénurie affecte
les récoltes reportage à suivre
la prise de parole de macky sall devant
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
le chef de l'état sénégalais et
président en exercice de l'union
africaine a réitéré son appel à l'octroi
d'un siège à l'ua au sein du g20 il a
également demandé à ce que l'on donne
plus de voix au continent africain au
sein du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
écouter
il est temps de vaincre les réticences
aidé à construire les narratif qui
persistent à confiner l'afrique à la
marche des sphères décisionnelles il est
temps de faire droit à la juste légitime
revendication
africaine sur la réforme du conseil de
sécurité
telles que reflétées dans le consensus
10 min
dans le même esprit
je rappelle notre demande d'octroi d'un
siège à l'union africaine au sein du g20
pour que l'afrique puisse enfin se faire
représenter là où se prennent les
décisions qui en âge 1 milliard 400
millions d'africains ce plaidoyer qui a
pour but de donner plus de place à
l'afrique sur la scène internationale et
dans les différentes institutions est un
symbole fort pour bruno daroux écoutez
son analyse
c'était vraiment un plaidoyer
effectivement pour qu'on reconnaisse
enfin le poids réel de l'afrique la
richesse de l'afrique la capacité
d'initiative de l'afrique de ce
continent de près d'un milliard et demi
d'habitants et c'était un discours avec
quelques phrases fortes quand même par
exemple l'afrique a suffisamment subi le
poids de l'histoire il y à l'afrique des
problèmes oui mais il y à aussi
l'afrique des solutions avec justement
toutes ses richesses minières
hydraulique 60% des terres arables sa
jeunesse absolument vibrante at il dit
et donc l'afrique peut amener beaucoup
au monde et il faut que le reste du
monde aujourd'hui sortent un peu de deux
schémas postcoloniaux enfin ça c'est mon
commentaire et reconnaissent aujourd'hui
l'afrique telle qu'elle est en 2022 et
lui accorde la place qu'elle mérite donc
effectivement une demande concernant un
siège pour l'union africaine au sein du
g20 une demande qui ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui d'une réforme du conseil
de sécurité des nations unies bref que
l'afrique soit parfaitement associés aux
prises de décisions comme un acteur sur
un pied d'égalité avec les autres
et marc perelman qui se trouve à new
york pour la 77e assemblée générale de
l'onu a pu s'entretenir avec geoffrey
oryema onyema pardon ministre nigérian
des affaires étrangères il est revenu
entre autres sur la situation au mali et
la levée des sanctions de la cedeao sur
le pays il s'est également exprimé sur
la crise diplomatique entre le mali et
la côte d'ivoire écouter
j'étais là bas au
moment j'ai rencontré
le président de la transition et nous
avions
fermement demandé
libération de ses 46
sur son pré conditions c'est quelque
chose très important pour nous tous dans
le cd ou de ne
pas laisser les choses aller plus loin
que maintenant donc on va tout faire
pour port pour empêcher que que ça ça ça
devient
un vrai conflit entre deux pays membres
de cdo
et puis ces messages d'excusés nous
avions diffusé dans notre édition du 7
septembre des images des wagner en
centrafrique alors que nous parlions de
la situation au mali nous tenons à nous
en excuser à nous excuser pour cette
erreur
on vous parlait hier d'un rapport
d'enquêteurs de l'onu qui accuse addis
abeba de possibles crimes contre
l'humanité au tigré et d'utiliser la
famine contre une arme de guerre et bien
sachez que l'ambassadeur de l'ethiopie
auprès des nations unies à genève a
rejeté ce mardi ce rapport et ses
accusations
les autorités sanitaires inquiète en
ouganda avec l'eau à metz elles ont
annoncé avoir détecté une flambée du
virus ebola dans le pays pour l'instant
le pays a enregistré un premier mort
trois ans après le dernier décès causés
par cette maladie mortelle
face à son premier décès du virus ebola
en trois ans
l'ouganda redouble de vigilance pour
éviter une nouvelle épidémie
le patient dont l'infection au virus
ebola a été confirmée est décédé
son corps est actuellement à l'
isolement dans la morgue
âgé de 24 ans le défunt avait été testé
positif à la souche dit soudanaise du
virus l'eau à metz indique que six
autres décès suspects ainsi que huit cas
potentiels tout survenue dans le
district de moumen des font actuellement
l'objet d'une enquête une fièvre
hémorragique hautement contagieuse le
virus ebola avait tué plus de 11000
personnes entre 2013 et 2016 en afrique
2 est mais les autorités sanitaires
ougandaise se disent confiantes
d'arriver à contenir cette nouvelle
flambée et annonce un renforcement des
opérations de sensibilisation dans le
district de mots bndes et
je tiens à rappeler au public et à la
communauté internationale que le
candidat est bien connu pour sa capacité
à gérer les épidémies
nous avons donc le savoir et les
compétences pour contenir le virus ebola
survenu en 2019 la dernière flambée
d'ebola en ouganda avait été rapidement
contrôlé grâce en partie à l'efficacité
du vaccin hervé beau contre la souche
dit zaïroise du virus aucun vaccin n'a
pour l'instant été approuvé pour lutter
contre le variant soudanais
en tunisie la police antiterroriste a
placé en détention ali larayedh anciens
premiers ministres et hauts responsables
du parti islamiste ennahda selon à ses
avocats il doit répondre de l'expédition
présumée de jihadistes en irak et en
syrie elle n'a ni les accusations et
estime qu'il s'agit d'une attaque
politique contre un opposant au
président kaïs aide
au burkina faso le procès de
l'assassinât du dirigeant syndical
étudiant boukari dabo en 1990 par l'ex
garde prétorienne de l'ancien président
blaise compaore s'est ouvert ce lundi à
ouagadougou en présence des principaux
accusés notamment le général gilbert
dienderé les détails de notre envoyé
spécial
ange nos manioc
après tron 2 en attente la sphère dabo
boukary refait surface au burkina faso
le procès de sept étudiants portés
disparus à la suite d'une manifestation
le 19 mai
1990 s'est ouvert ce lundi 19 septembre
au tribunal de ouagadougou il n'aurait
été enlevées plus tant qu'ils auraient à
mort par les éléments de la sécurité
présidentielle kg t à l'époque par le
général gilbert diendéré ce dernier dit
n'avoir pas donné d'ordre et rejette
toute participation à l'arrestation des
étudiants il est poursuivi ainsi que
deux autres personnes le médecin colonel
mamadou bamba étudiant à l'époque et
magloire yougbaré sergent au moment des
faits ils sont tous les trois accusés de
complicité d'arrestation illégale et de
séquestration aggravée complicité de
coups et blessures ayant entraîné la
mort sans intention de la donner et
recel de cadavres la famille de la
victime espère connaître la vérité sur
l'assassinât de dabo boukary le procès
suit son cours et devraient se
poursuivre jusqu'à ce mercredi 28
septembre
gilbert diendéré et comme déjà de 20 ans
de prison pour le putsch manqué de 2015
l'ancien bras droit de l'ex président
blaise compaoré a été reconnu coupable
d'attentât à la sûreté de l'état et
meurtre
les conséquences de la guerre en ukraine
sur l'agriculture la production agricole
de cette année est fortement menacée
dans des pays comme la guinée qui
importe une grande partie de son engrais
en de russie les agriculteurs guinéen
exposés à une flambée des prix et une
pénurie de ces fertilisants s'attendent
à de mauvaises récoltes cette année
reportage d'elimane dao et de mali
diakité
ousmane était inquiet cet exploitant
agricole possède des chats d'ananas à
kindia à 115 km à l'est de conakry il
s'attend à de faibles rendements cette
année le prix des engrais a explosé
suite à la guerre en ukraine et aux
difficultés d'approvisionnement en
fertilisant ces intrants coûte
excessivement cher il ya un an sa côte
est vingt mille francs le sachet et le
même 6 h est aujourd'hui souvent à 40000
fin donc 100 %
d'augmentation donc si vous devez
acheter pour
l'été tout ce champ que vous voyez vous
comprendrez que les moyens risque d'être
de faire
défaut en fait aux marchés de kindia lui
règle mpk et la potasse les principaux
engrais utilisés dans la région ne sont
pas disponibles en quantité suffisante à
cause de prix élevés et de la pénurie
sur le marché international
il n'y a même pas une tonne d'engrais
c'est qu'on sent obligé d'aller chercher
l'anglais au mali au sénégal parfois
même en gambie pour avoir pour pouvoir
satisfaire le client la tonne d'engrais
est passé sur le marché international de
500 $ avant le début de la crise
ukrainiennes ou doubles ces derniers
mois le ministre de l'agriculture guinée
assurent toutefois prendre toutes les
précautions pour soulager les
producteurs les petits se soit montrée
seychelles
comme on le dit c'est la crise mondiale
on a espoir de gagner des nouveaux des
nouveaux stocks il était vraiment temps
de faire des efforts donc la transition
a été très clair sur l'agriculture c'est
une priorité absolue
la situation est préoccupante pour les
dîners vivant en milieu rural qui
représente une grande majorité de la
population selon le fonds international
de développement agricole
63% d'entre eux sont touchés par la
pauvreté
vous ne le savez peut-être pas mais le
premier producteur de jasmin au monde
c'est l'égypte c'est dans le pays des
pharaons que pousse l'une des variétés
les plus appréciés au monde nous vous
emmenons ce soir dans un village au nord
du caire où est produit la majorité du
jasmin mondial caroline l'embolie
la plupart des consommateurs connaissent
son parfum floral mais ils ne savent pas
qu'une grosses quantités produites
mondialement provient d'ici le village
de choubra bello là au nord du caire
une activité économique qui emploient la
majorité de ses 15000 habitants
notre village est connu pour la culture
et la récolte du jasmin cette plante est
essentiel pour notre village
on ne peut pas accueillir le jasmin
n'importe quand
on peut cueillir les fleurs tôt le matin
à partir de 1h mais dès qu'il commence à
faire chaud lafleur ne sera plus en état
si on l'accueille
mais ces dernières années n'ont pas été
florissantes pour les cultivateurs la
crise sanitaire duo qu'ovide 19 et la
gare en ukraine ont freiné les
exportations
la guerre entre la russie et l'ukraine a
aussi eu un impact car avant la russie a
apporté une grosse partie de notre
production il ya aussi eu un impact sur
les consommateurs qui ont peur et qu'ils
n'achètent plus qu'il considère comme ne
pas être nécessaire comme par exemple
mais par
un autre défi selon ce professionnel du
secteur le changement climatique qui
fait diminuer la production
mais l'egypte reste malgré tout parmi
les premiers producteurs du monde elle
exporte un concentré est extrait de la
fleur nommé absolue il est ensuite
utilisée pour produire des parfums en
europe et ailleurs
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
audrey racines
[Musique]